hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion eins hört zu und spricht nach
hallo hallo ich heiße stefan ich heiße
stefan wie heißen sie
wie heißen sie
ich heiße tina ich heiße tina ich heiße
michael ich heiße
michael woher kommen sie
woher kommen sie
ich komme aus der schweiz
ich komme aus deutschland
ich komme aus deutschland welche sprache
sprechen sie welche sprache sprechen sie
ich spreche deutsch ich spreche deutsch
ich spreche französisch ich spreche
französisch
wohnen sie wo wohnen sie
ich wohne in zürich ich wohne in zürich
ich wohne in basel
ich wohne in basel das alphabet das
alphabet diana a wie anna b 7b 7c wie
claudia c wie claudia d
wie daniel d
wie daniel
wma wma avi franziska f wie franziska g
wie gabriel wie gabriel wie hans h wie
hans wie isabelle wie isabell ott wie
jonas j wie jonas k
wie kevin k wie kevin wie leer wie leer
[Musik]
wie michael wie michael wie nina wie
nina wie oliver wie oliver p
wie peter p
wie peter wie quentin wie quentin wie
robert wie robert es wie sophie es wie
geoffrey t
wie tina t wie tina ursula wie ursula
wie vanessa wie vanessa wie walter w wie
walter dix wie xenia wie xenia y wie
yvonne y wie yvonne
z wie z
[Musik]
wi2wi österreich wie österreich wie
südafrika wie südafrika ägypten wie
ägypten wie schweden wie schweden wie
spanien wie spanien wie schweiz
[Musik]
wie schweiz wie griechenland wie
griechenland wie china wie honduras wie
honduras wie philippinen wie philippinen
[Musik]
wie deutschland wie deutschland ich
heiße monika müller
ich komme aus deutschland ich wohne in
zürich ich spreche deutsch ich heiße
francesca gummi
ich komme aus der schweiz ich wohne in
lugano
ich spreche italienisch ich heiße eric
laval ich komme aus kanada ich wohne in
genf ich spreche französisch